so today I'm going to be talking about
two topics both in domains having to do
with mathematics and those are
mathematical constants and the Riemann
hypothesis so let me just jump right in
so first couldn't talk about constants
so while I'm doing that let me tell you
about how constants have been exposed
previously through Wolfram Alpha of
course you're all familiar with control
equals and equals equals those great
natural language discovery mechanisms
and historically in previous versions
you could type in if you are interested
in mathematical constant that you knew
about you could type in a name and get a
lot of good information on it so for
instance pi here is probably the most
famous mathematical constant and we see
all the information that alpha would
give you this is the same as what you'd
see on the website I just happen to have
it running in my local session here but
you know you could also get this with in
mathematic as I said through equal equal
just as another example Catalan is a
little bit less familiar of a constant
perhaps but we get a lot of good
information continued fraction
information alternative representations
ways you can write it in other
mathematical forms series
representations and so on so constants
have been in alpha for quite a while and
so this is nothing new in a sense but
there are some new oh yeah and let me
let me just quickly wanted to mention a
few maybe just interesting cases that
you may have not now run into but you
know the one of the fun things about
constants is is they're they're sort of
simple in a way they're simpler than say
mathematical functions which is a topic
I talked about last year you know
there's no complicated mmm and a
logistic indicial ike this but they tell
you they pop up in interesting ways you
find so for instance the first example
i've got here try Bonacci z' constant is
an analogue to it's the limit of the
Trib anoche sequence
as the terms go to infinity where the
Trib anoche sequence is similar to
fibonacci which you're probably all
familiar with however it takes three
terms
thus the tri in the name and
interestingly this sort of constant that
that arises through a limit of a series
actually also comes into play having to
do with the the length of a side and the
geometry of this shape you see here
which is called a truncated icosahedron
there's other other you know interesting
interesting from a physical point of
view constants I hear an example of the
diamond lattice percolation threshold
constant which says if you have a
diamond lattice and you start activating
points what fraction of those points do
you have to choose before there is a
phase transition where you have a long
range connected set of lattice points
and so this has interest in the physical
world even though the constants I'm
talking about at this point are are not
physical constants they're all
mathematical you can all drive them with
pencil and paper or or maybe a computer
in some cases we don't talk about
dimension full constants for instance in
this in this domain but still one's a
physical interest do occur and then
there are just some fun ones this one
wodsworth constant refers to the
fraction of a of a youtube video that
you have to skip over to get to the
interesting part and that has
empirically been determined to be 3/10
some people may have have other bounds
on that constant but that's what we have
so so let me talk about the goals of
wire why are we wanting to change the
way constants are treated in alpha first
of all we want exposure in the Wolfram
language in a way where you can you can
get say the series representations
without having to retype them yourself
you know without copying and pasting
from the Wolfram Alpha output we want to
extend the content we've got because
Wolfram Alpha when I started working on
this domain had about 240 constants
defined in it
at this point we've got in the pipeline
over 500 right now and the the Virgin
I'm going to show you today we have just
about 400 constants exposed many of
which come from a series of sources
those of you who have interest in
mathematical constants I'm sure are all
familiar with many of these Finch wrote
a great book where we've tried to get
everything that he's given us and then
things like the OE is the online
encyclopedia of integer sequences and
you know math world which is Eric's era
see Eric sitting here he's his baby
we've scraped for some some constants
there as well so so that's that's sort
of the goals so let's look at what we've
got at the moment this is the current
list of mathematical constants and just
looking through the name sort of
scanning you can see there's a wide
variety of things there's things like
the grazing goat constant you know
things from Gauss so so things that have
been around for a while all kinds of
stuff and you know I won't belabor it by
trying to to read off too many of these
but as I said we've got about 400 right
now and more in the pipeline that that
will be exposed before version 11.1
given a list of the properties so we can
see that there's what we call so first
of all classes tells you about entity
classes for those of you familiar with
the entity framework defining formula is
like and I'll kind of follow along with
the example I've given below for the
alati Grinstead constant the defining
formula tells you sort of how do you
write down what this thing is in a
closed form if possible or as an
infinite sum or whatever form we have
you know what what is it we've got a
numerical approximation and where
possible what we've tried to do is
return a thousand digits so that you
know there's a fair amount
precision you can get without having to
compute yourself and also in the future
we're going to try and return sort of
methods or functions by which you can
calculate more digits for certain of
these constants where such a algorithm
exists and and we can return that for
you there's things like integral
representations limit representations
these are things that if any of you have
played around with mathematical function
data you're familiar with but just to
give you some example here for a lot of
Grinstead you see what a series
representation would look like it's you
know something with that involves an
infinite sum or perhaps even a finite
sum but so we have very various forms of
representations we have a short
numerical approximation that just is
because you may not want to look at
these thousand digits when you're trying
to scan through of say a table that
you've created so we give a shorter
version to 16 digits which I don't see
here for this particular entity but oh
no here it is here so obviously this
will be a little bit nicer to look at if
you're looking through a lot of them
we've got simple continued fraction
terms so here are the first few terms in
this case looks like about a hundred
terms we have for the continued fraction
representation of of a lot e Grinstead
and then we give a traditional notation
and a standard notation so that you can
use these perhaps in your session if you
want to write a paper or just talk about
them in traditional form you've got
something there to use okay here's
another example just showing you boilers
you know the the base of natural
logarithm constant and here we've got of
course a lot more data because this is a
much more fleshed out constant in the
literature you can see the nice pattern
you get with the continued fraction
simple continued fraction of e to those
of you who are familiar with that
pattern so yeah just just giving you an
overview sense of what data is here now
one one sort of very important use case
that we wanted to address when we were
sort of building this domain is you know
if if someone comes with a number that
they're trying to identify and and some
of you may have seen David Soto Myers
talked yesterday about a similar topic
but you may want to identify you know
I've I've done some I've got some
physical model or some mathematical
computation I've done I want to know
this 12 digit number I've got out could
that be represented by any closed form
solution or other well known number and
so that's why we wanted to build in some
discovery mechanisms to allow you to do
that sort of thing so for instance in
11.1 there's a function called
mathematical constant data and you can
see here how it behaves
you can now there there's a bunch of
different argument structures you can
pass here but for the purposes of of
what I want to talk about right now I'm
just going to point out that you can
submit an interval as the first argument
and it will return all of the constants
that we have knowledge about that are
within that interval so here you see all
the constants between 1 & 2 maybe that's
not the most interesting sort of query
but what if you know what if you
discovered this great new number 3.1415
and you wanted to know what that might
be
you could put in this interval and you
discover well it's either pi or an
approximation for pi or it may be it's
something we've never heard of before
but those are the possibilities that we
know about ok and another method for
discovering these entities is our
implicit entity classes and I'm going to
show you the syntax here unfortunately I
can't execute this piece of code because
I'm right now running Mathematica 10 on
my machine and this is new and 11 and
and later so what you see here is sort
of the syntax you you can ask for
entities that have a certain property
the property in a certain range
so here I've asked for all the
mathematical constants between negative
infinity and zero so those would give
you all the negative constants for
instance oh and did I did I show you the
entity classes oh yeah I forgot to
mention
before on this previous slide the entity
class as you can see we've got a large
collection of different sets of
constants so another way you could get
all of the negative constants is just by
querying this entity class negative
constants so and and there's a variety
of other collections there that may be
of interest okay so that's all I wanted
to talk about right now on mathematical
constant data but I would encourage you
at the moment what you know you know as
it's released to explore if you have an
interest let us know if there's other
constants that you're interested in that
you'd like to have data put into the
system for let us know any any
suggestions you have would be great
because we want to make this as a
complete or repository as possible so
before I transition to my next topic
which is the Riemann hypothesis project
I wanted to take this opportunity to
thank the people who are involved
besides myself of course there's there's
people like Oleg narrative and Eric
Weinstein who you're all familiar with
and I don't think they need any more
accolades from me but these interns did
a great work
this past summer and previous summers
collecting so so Albert Tam is an here
he collected information on mathematical
constants and functions and amita and a
random here collected the work that I'm
about to show you on the Riemann
hypothesis and believe me they're
mathematical extra beauty expertise
exceeds mine quite a bit and I wouldn't
have not have been able to do this work
without them so let's go now to the
Riemann hypothesis project so the the
goals here are there's a few of them
first of all we've tried in the past
here at Wolfram several instances of
trying to collect pure mathematics
formal mathematics knowledge that is
opposed to what people typically use
Mathematica for which would be
computational mathematics how do I do
this integral what is the population of
France that kind of thing where you're
returning numbers or expressions here we
want to return really just conceptual
things things built of concepts if you
will maybe that's the best way to say it
and we've tried that in various in car
in the past there's been there was a
project to collect results dealing with
continued fractions that we put a lot of
work into there's a theorem
formalization project and mathematical
mathematical formulation formalization
project that is going to be spoken about
in the talk I think it's immediately
following my talk right now so please
stick around for that it's really
interesting work and another example is
work on function spaces which Eric
weisstein has on I misspelled your name
I apologize Eric weisstein has worked on
and I'm actually not sure when your talk
is Eric but you can all check these ok
there you go so so please go to Eric's
talk as well
another reason we we chose this this
topic is because there's a relatively
small amount of what we're I'll explain
what these are in a minute here but
they're sort of alternative formulations
of the Riemann hypothesis and there may
be in the literature on the order of a
hundred I don't think we've collected
them all necessarily we've collected a
large fraction of them but you know
that's sort of at a number where over
the summer we could get our interns and
and sort of complete the project or get
it you know 75% of the way completed so
that we can say we have a sort of we
have all the knowledge collected about
these particular types of entities and
the other interesting thing about it is
that unlike some of the other projects
maybe maybe say function space work
which is really interesting and
important but we don't necessarily have
a powerful enough language yet to
represent everything we'd want to in
that type of domain whereas you know
surprisingly or maybe perhaps not
surprisingly the Riemann hypothesis is
sort of simple enough to state that
we've got most of the pieces built into
the language already and so that's what
made it a good project to tackle in this
sort of manner so let's just look at
what data we've collected we've got
right now 46 entities collected over the
summer by random and Amita and you can
see there's a variety of names there
mainly associated with people you know
who's ever published it in the
literature
has their name attached to it many of
these don't have their own name although
we'll talk about one in a minute that
does and what type of properties are we
going to are we going to be able to look
at for these well we've got references
so you know if you look at one of these
entities you want to go to the
literature see what paper it was in you
can find that we've got the dates they
were formulated we've got who formulated
them and that's that's linking into
people data so you can do entity value
of the person that formulated this find
out more information about their
biography perhaps we've got the
relationship to the Riemann hypothesis
so when we collected these we we found
that there were a class of these
formulations or statements that were
equivalent to the Riemann hypothesis
some that are consequences of the
Riemann hypothesis and of course there
are some statements that are stronger
than the Riemann hypothesis that then
imply the Riemann hypothesis so we
wanted to you know basically state in a
simple way what that relationship was
and so here you and and then the most
important perhaps is the statement
formulation so you can actually see the
formal mathematical expression for what
these things state and I've given an
example here first of all the Riemann
hypothesis itself so those of you who
are unfamiliar perhaps it's a kind of an
esoteric statement if you're not
familiar with analytical number theory
but the statement is that all of the
non-trivial zeros of the riemann zeta
function which is a special mathematical
function occur on the line real part
equal to a half okay so that may not
seem like that interesting of a topic
but of course it's a it's a famous
unsolved problem it's been unsolved for
150 years and another part perhaps the
the reason that it has such interest in
the community is because it's related to
the distribution of prime numbers and of
course you know everyone who's studied
mathematics and been sort of fascinated
by it at any point in their life has
probably thought about prime numbers and
and and been attracted to that so so
interesting and interesting
field of study so let's look at how the
Riemann hypothesis actually works if you
try and formalize it in the Wolfram
language we can see that so first of all
we wrapped this in a pure function
that's merely two so that so that some
of these symbols we can give you
you can choose sort of what symbols to
put in here this is following the syntax
of Wolfram excuse me a mathematical
function data but so what does this say
it says that for all Z where Zeta equals
zero there exists an N and greater than
zero so so so basically this part of the
statement is is taking care of the
trivial zeros those are the ones that
are at the negative even integers so
it's saying that either there exists an
N which is a negative even integer such
that Z is equal to that or Z is equal to
1/2 plus a complex a purely complex part
see Y is real I times y is a complex
excuse me an imaginary part and then
you've got the one-half so this is
exactly the statement that all the
non-trivial zeros are on the critical
line real part equal 1/2 so do we have
the other version of this statement so
as I said this is known to be equivalent
or actually implies what's known as the
prime number theorem well it's actually
it implies the prime number theorem but
it is also equivalent to a stronger
statement called the prime number
estimate which gives some bounds on the
so the prime number s theorem says that
the number of primes below a certain
number approaches this log integral
function as the number as the numbers
get larger and larger the prime number
estimate just puts excuse me
prime number estimate just puts a
particular bound on this so it says how
fast those numbers converge I see I'm
running short on time so I'll try and go
quickly through this last bit just to
give you a sense of the different types
of formulations that you might find here
you have ones that involve in infinite
sums integrals integral transforms
limits derivatives and often these Big O
little low estimates those of you who
may be familiar with Big O and little o
notation these are sort of statements
about the asymptotics of various
functions and these are this is an
example where some of these constructs
did not occur in the Wolfram language so
what I said earlier is true that the
majority of this can be expressed in the
wolf language some of it could not so we
had to invent our own symbols for Big O
and little O and those are returned as
part of these these formulations
I just gave here a grid so you can see
all of them laid out and you can see
they're relatively short statements
usually they're there things that you
know we can we can this is sort of proof
of proof of statement that all of this
can be expressed within the Wolfram
language and I had a few more things but
I think rather than that I will just
pause here and see if there are any
questions
[Applause]